even as the Tory party slices policies
off its mini budgets a few miles away on
the other side of town work continues as
normal
here at Birmingham case makers their
hand making display boxes for medals and
honors
it's a hidden part of the British
establishment so what did they make of
today's antics
I think it's a little hey it's a little
like a roller coaster it would be nice
to have consistency notice about fluency
it would nice it would be nice to be
able to plan
uh we seriously there are lots of new
things that are being thrown against the
war without a lot of thought behind them
and certainly if you dig a Little Deeper
it's almost packet planning
and the last thing we need at the moment
with what is going on globally is fact
Becky planning
but there's a deeper question markets
have been volatile ever since the
Chancellor's mini budget will the
government's change of mind on the 45p
tax rate finally turn their pessimism
into bullishness optimism
what is it that makes markets bullish
it's tempting to think it's all about
rationality but in reality it's other
things it's emotions it's fear it's
greed it's confidence it's credibility
it's vibes
it's not entirely clear actually what
single measure markets were so revolted
by when it came to this mini budget and
by the same token it's not clear which
measure the government could you turn on
to change their minds
and there was some precious good news
for the chancellor today after that news
emerged the pound strengthened against
the dollar hitting the highest level
since his mini budget
Liz truss's economic advisors worry that
this is the beginning of a bigger climb
down I don't think it's a game changer
it's not that important for the economy
or that bigger part of the the mini
budget but what it might do is actually
increase uncertainty in some ways um if
you're a believer in in trust nonics as
as I am you might be worried that this
would embolden the critics of the policy
not just um outside the conservative
party but also within it in the end much
of this comes back to something far too
difficult to quantify credibility if the
government has lost the faith of markets
even a U-turn of this scale may not be
enough to convince them to change their
mind about the UK economy
at Conway Sky News in Birmingham